hello everybody and welcome to part two
of let's play nightmare house - I have
to change my fraps button because it is
set to f9 and as we all know that is
infamously the valve save button or load
button quick load anyway that's gonna
probably be a problem oh this looks like
a spectral horror from another dimension
who are you who the hell are you
oh come here I'm gonna get you oh oh
don't even try to get up get up
yeah run away oh you left your doll you
big baby
your left Oh your new booty - Oh fu man
Oh dead-bang done Oh get out of here -
reload I already know that it's pretty
much a staple for every first-person
shooter ever made oh you're oh you were
so scared you hung yourself I don't
blame you
ready to come in all on now you're done
hey where'd you go where'd you go hey
whoa
haha not quite didn't get me
still not scared hey hi
Oh boob Oh bang II gone a hall
you left your face on the other side of
the room oh yeah
come on where am I going
how am I going what's going on what's
going on yeah here I can spread fast
I'll be useful for what am i doing
what's going on
get open you you want some that's why I
thought nobody wants some nobody
let's see all right been there don't
look like there's anything useful
Oh oh yeah give me that oh yeah oh yeah
get back funky cat oh oh poor little
baby
whatever yeah Oh finally
aha hey alright alright good at the
jumps i getcha
alright let's just see how good you are
in hand-to-hand combat oh [ __ ] get away
get away
Oh fu oh yeah took you out with my axe
oh you you you yeah you're now gonna see
how spastically I am it quicksaving
never I get in a game like this I can
say all the bloody time
oh what's that oh you in pain gonna be
and this accident sixteen gunshots
alright
my battery recharged on that nothing
nothing looking for a key of some sort
shotgun shells always like those boom
got out of here boom I said screw
hanging come on didn't get a headshot
all right let me reload ooh lots of
bullets I'm using this up key give me
doing key oh really really this is how I
gotta do it oh yeah after you get
where's my shotgun good who left someone
laughs some of you magically watching
this live stream somehow whatever
whatever I'm moving forward bring it on
I'll bring it up oh oh gonna trap me eh
I'm ready already bring it on let me oh
yeah oh who wants some
who wants some no one oh okay all right
oh no don't break again
very upset I'm guessing something bad
happened in this house probably open up
hey what was that
who's making noises hey get out of here
gone oh sorry
alright got some of your brains on me
that's fire
that's it that's a left 4 dead 2 fire
right there and if you know what I mean
well high five to you
all right Oh watch it Oh home nothing
oh it's game acting like it's scared but
it's not oh oh terrifying bowl of
oranges Oh what's this nothing nothing
even cut you in half you weren't even on
the toilet you don't have an excuse
I guess not that that Billy is a valid
excuse but whatever whatever you know
what I mean all right
Oh leap or epicly oh yeah who's down
there
nobody all right um nothing maybe I was
supposed to fall Oh ladder okay good
attitude
okay Oh something gonna be at the top I
bet come on oh I'm ready oh I'm so ready
bring it aah Oh ready but God Oh get out
of here get out of here Oh fu
get the [ __ ] off what the that was just
[ __ ]
god damn it all right whatever that's
cool
Oh bring it bring it
oh just bring it on man all my health in
the beginning I don't know how a bike
one who stores their bike in the top
floor bull honkey I call boy I'll get
out of here get out of here Oh
trap door thank you very much all right
and the layout in this house is terrible
whoever designed it it's falling apart
the rooms go nowhere oh [ __ ] oh god yeah
oh oh man oh that was a good one oh that
was good that made my skin crawl
goodness gravy
oh no really not scared a little girl
but when they just stop [ __ ] you ah god
damn it bring it are you your supper
bang oh you fam nothing nothing
oh man seriously I got goose bumps last
one not the last one before I felt
alright and I almost oh that's a front
door okay where I'm from where room tall
this year not that one
[Applause]
[Music]
nope
ah [ __ ] you get out of here didn't think
so
oh why did I even go in the ah [ __ ] you
a screw you yes I can
okay all right well Wow
I mean wow for a short little thing I
know that was just the prologue but man
good Anya
everyone good recommendation this was
something man
and there's like that was just one part
the other part has like six for a mod
this is incredible I like it
love it love it love it love it all
right what do we got here uh okay here
we go all right bring it back into the
house I hope it'll be a little bit of a
better layout than the last one same as
it always was isn't it no the mine just
keeps it interesting
your situation I don't find comfort
anymore oh yeah wake up it's time for
the real I'll bring it all
nightmare house 2
all that Excel that make sense
alright okay open animal okay
nothing here all right I'm actually
gonna pause it here thank you guys so
much for watching I really do appreciate
it and stick around for the next part of
nightmare house actually I think it'll
probably be technically the beginning of
nightmare house too because the last one
knows this prologue but anyway thanks
for watching I'll see you next time bye
bye